[Music]
tim
oh no do you ever get those days where
where you would
where's the bathroom yeah anyway
so what i was trying to ask you is do
you ever get those
days where it's just like there's just
too much going on where it would be
really nice and comforting
if a stranger just looked you in the
eyes and told you
i'm a [ __ ] yo
[Laughter]
okay you could have a back that was good
i hate strangers but what if the
stranger is nice
wait finish please oh you finished
you're just kidding
so they look you in the eye and they say
everything's gonna be okay you're doing
your best
you're doing the best you can i'd like
shut the [ __ ] up you don't know me
[ __ ]
weirdo you don't know who the [ __ ] i am
like don't [ __ ] touch me
so when you're gonna suck my dick yeah
uh would that be helpful at all if a
stranger came up to me and said that it
depends if it was
a little old lady it would be nice yeah
not for me if i was stressing out a
little old lady was like
oh you know what you're gonna be just
fine yeah well i'm like
she has to be an old lady thanks little
old lady it helps if a dude came up to
me it was like hey hey everything i'd be
like
all right dog chill like okay you don't
know me bro chill out
but what if you are doing great and
they're just kind of like everything
i know it's all right it's been amazing
are you okay
you get all offended yeah i'm like you
don't know what do i look like to you
right now i look depressed
they're like kind of i mean your hair
like you haven't had a bro let me just
buy a haircut for you like
i got you i know you're [ __ ] he's
drinking coffee
on the street damn that's the only like
those things only matter to me if it's
people that i care about
yeah same you know so if i don't yeah if
i don't know who the [ __ ] you are
get away from me well what if you paid a
dollar for this oh dollar
for that service i'm gonna take the
dollar back if anything i
pay for i don't feel like is right
except for a massage
what do you mean like any type of like
service where it's like
someone's gonna give me some positivity
or motivational things or whatever
i'm like nah not genuine because you got
paid for it yeah i'll pay you for the
massage
but nothing else so you're not the type
of guy to fall in love with strippers
then
i pay for my friends to get strippers
because i like to watch them from afar
do strippers tell you everything's gonna
be all right
don't worry every single day no they say
do you want a lap dance honey you want a
party
that's what they say because he if he
knows that he's paying for it it's not
genuine to him yeah it's you
it's not my stripper tells me
everything's gonna be all right i'm like
damn what did i do with my life how did
i end up here
all right well there's this pizza this
pizza shop
in brooklyn called vinnie's brooklyn
pizza
sounds delicious yeah so they
have added a new option to their
delivery
service and it's called positive
reinforcement it says comforting words
for one dollar our delivery driver will
look you straight in the eyes
and tell you everything's gonna be okay
you're doing
the best you can hey maybe that's what
people need in new york because
new york is [ __ ] up hey i'm walking
here yeah people are
mean man i know right look at this look
at this elote pizza
pizza oh man there's a spot there's a
spot
i like pizza well yeah twenty three
dollars for a large pizza large cheese
pizza oh come on
jason twenty it's an elote pizza again
one for the cheese pizza
23 for this new york is supposed to have
the best pizza in the game it's
really expensive more than italy that's
new york prices they should include the
compliment
with those prices times are tough you
can't support a small business what's
wrong with you jason pretty sure that's
not yeah but
then thank yous don't cost anything when
they
when they when you when you go to a
restaurant they go thank you
you don't have to pay for that but if
they're a grumpy new yorker you have to
yeah see that's how [ __ ] up new york
is you have to actually pay for
positivity maybe they do need a little
extra encouragement out there i can see
it
50 cents for a smile it is a weird time
it is a weird time and some people are
stuck in the house by themselves
yeah for an extra dollar i take my mask
off and smile at you it's like
[Laughter]
no like smizing just only fans that's
what that
was flash of titties she said ten
dollars flash of titty not me personally
i'm saying they can you could charge way
more yeah yeah oh but it's not as good
when you have to pay for it
there we go back to this point i like it
when it's free i like how you're all
pouty
is it the same if you have to pay for it
it's what i'm saying oh i feel you you
mean like it's
like the comp like the encouraging words
it doesn't feel like it's real
encouraging words it feels
like i've encouraged you and you go shut
the [ __ ] up geo and i'm like all right
man my bad
that's true that's him accepting it
that's his way of accepting
i don't need encouragement i think more
than anything it's a
it's a it's a cute idea that's gonna get
them exposure online here we go we're
talking about vinnie's
so cute and they're 23 pizza good
oh is that male 1 i don't know about
that what ranch
mac and cheese that's oh [ __ ] i want
barbecue chicken i'm guessing i'm
guessing all this oh this looks like a
buffalo chicken situation yeah
i'm down to try it that does look really
good i'm sorry
i'm a traditional guy i only go for
pepperoni me too
you wouldn't be down for this i'm a
pepper only pepperoni
wow that was fire was that off the top
off the top of my head like i just made
that up like are you being sarcastic
yes oh you remember okay that was good
if i wanted to speak
that they foreign you were you were
idiots
wasn't he right rick no but i remember
at one point wasn't he in it was he i
don't think so oh
what are you talking about i thought
that was fire it's a pepper
ollie oh yeah pepper only
it's such an old video i thought you
were being sarcastic if i want to live
on the wild side i just go
extra pepperoni really i stopped eating
pepperoni after
i would get a lot of heartburn when i
was pregnant i don't believe they
actually put extra pepperoni
yeah you could see the difference you
could tell it's covered man
it looks like fish scales i love how
skeptical you are man
i like that what do you think they do
they spread it out more
whenever i get extra cheese or extra
pepperoni it looks exactly the same
where are you going man papa john's
that's why that's probably why you got
to be like
hey i want it covered in pepperoni i
wanna
if it's extra is not enough give me
extra extra and charge it [ __ ] i don't
give a
[ __ ] i'm rich [ __ ] i want that [ __ ] to
come out
looking like fish scales yeah or you got
to do you got to get a control group
pizza like
can i get a pepperoni pizza and then i
want another pizza
that's extra pepperoni and now we can
open the two
and double check that's smart i want
extra extra extra to the point
where it looks like a dragon scale scale
are y'all
are you all pineapple yeah pizza people
i like my mouth everybody
no no no no one huh interesting
if it's there i'll eat one um it just
say it's like
nasty gooey in my mouth i don't like
sweet stuff on my pizza i love
the i love that that's like my favorite
salty and sweet
complimenting each other do you like the
meat lovers special
where they got canadian bacon i like
that too sausage
crumbs i [ __ ] with the meat lovers you
know what i do now since i'm off cheese
i'll find the places that like where i
can get vegan cheese but then i'll order
meat lovers pizza and people get really
confused
like i'll be like all right can i get it
with vegan cheese but like the meat
lovers
and they're like do you you know it's
real meat though i'm like yes foo
i know i'm like that's full i can't eat
dairy [ __ ] i'm like i don't care
about the animals i just i just i'm not
eating cheese
what's the vegan cheese made out of then
i don't know
tofu who knows who the [ __ ] knows i just
know it's not yeah it tastes different
um it definitely tastes different like
it's not like real cheese
you know um but it does the trick for
what i'm trying to do in my life
so casey gets pizza with no cheese and
with anchovies
he's a [ __ ] ninja turtle and some
other form of meat
no ninja turtles like cheese i never had
anchovy because of the fact that he's
trying to stay away from cheese so he
if he if it was up to him he would put
cheese on it but because he's trying to
god y'all are married i don't think you
would have stuck around if you saw that
[ __ ] at first
on the first date imagine [ __ ] this
guy's a [ __ ] cereal
i'm like we're staying as a booty call
that's it like sir
you're eating a tuna sandwich right now
with tomato sauce
i never had anchovy pizza oh he gets it
sometimes and he
so for his pizza though he has to put it
like far away
does it stink where can you even get
ancho
i want to try dominoes no way that's
where we order people
are you [ __ ] kidding me whenever
we're not doing like at-home people
i digiorno well we're there we don't
have a partnership so
anymore you [ __ ] up the journal i
always heard about it right like i
remember
like back in the day all the all the
shows they'll be like
ew anchovy pizza so then because it was
already branded as gross
i never tried it that was me with ninja
turtles that's why i made that reference
i only knew about it because of ninja
turtles did you ever eat anchovies
growing up though
yeah nah one of the things that my
grandma started doing was putting
anchovy in our rice like when you
steamed rice
oh that sounds good it actually tastes
really good yeah that's good well
actually have you ever had like
is it like a caesar like the traditional
caesar salads are made out of anchovies
oh really can you do that real quick
just before before i say some [ __ ]
that's what i'd watch like cartoons and
stuff
i just i want to be accurate i always
use live anchovies for bait too
where salad caesar salad google
anchovies okay so if you've ever had
table sized
sauce caesar salad where they make the
dressing
next to your table they'll put in real
like anchovies and [ __ ] and it's like
it's so good because traditional caesar
salad has anchovies i don't know that
the only time i've tried anchovies is is
when we were in italy and they were
doing the little
the little like [ __ ] i forgot what
they're called but they look prosciutto
bruschetta
no i don't think it's that one chopped
tomatoes and the the taglia pico de
gallo good thing
no or maybe i don't remember but it's
like a little piece of bread that's
really thick and then they put
a piece of fish on top
i like that too what was this at italy
oh and
venice oh that's where i tried it pizza
in italy is so good
yeah dude oh well i was supposed to go
but roan
ha ha you didn't get to go home
oh you know what you're going to get a
better experience than what we had
because you're going to have like a
clean venice hopefully
because it's all flooded don't be nice
ha ha you didn't go
you can't be part of the conversation
i've never been either
hey maybe we could go together when are
you going when rona goes away
okay can i come to you nope no oh come
on
yeah you can go yay okay but jason
you know where the pizza's at everywhere
dude okay
then you're not invited you were about
to be invited but not anymore you were
valuable but didn't you go
to a chinese neighborhood in italy to
perform your music
in florence no casey went with you to
florence
we went to spain now i just picture you
going to all the restaurants in italy
being like
is there pizza here i just want pizza
my pizza they're so good
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you